yeah i think when i came to detroit
there was a lot of work to do and that's
what we're trying to do
um but uh you know talking about this
year right now we're talking about right
now
uh you know these first four games and
obviously today wasn't good enough i
think
after four games you know our team can
really take a look at itself and say
okay hey
how do we need to play the games what do
we got to do we got some work to do
during the bye week here i think which
will be good for us to really take a
look at
how do we need to play going forward and
i think that's probably the most
important
thing from that standpoint is what do we
do going forward um and how do we win
matt patricia embattled head coach of
the lions year three
of his effort to try to turn the team
around
and and i think he may have
inadvertently stepped on a land mine
when he made that comment there was a
lot of work to do when i got here
because he's had pushback
from folks who say wait a minute it's
not like jim caldwell
was stinking the joint up no they had
been to the playoffs they had been nine
and seven
here's the reality when bob quinn was
hired and this is why i don't like this
two tracks i hear you mike you're right
we have a coach and we're hiring a gm no
fire everybody just fire everybody and
let the new gm start over
don't fire the gm and keep the coach
because the gm is just gonna bide his
time
until he gets to hire his own coach
that's how it always works
so instead of firing caldwell remember
early on bob quinn made caldwell just
kind of wait
yeah and wonder and i think quinn
talked to some other people who may have
done things different ways you know some
gms went in and fired the coach
immediately others gave them a chance
the problem is you've given the chance
they may do well enough
right it makes it hard to finally rip
off the band-aid and now
when matt patricia has failed to take
the
team to where jim caldwell had them
patricia's in jeopardy quinn's in
jeopardy and the question is
how long do the lions want to try this
this patriot way in the upper midwest
approach at what point do they just say
it's not working
and we need to go in a different
direction yeah well they're getting
close to that i don't think there's any
denying that
i mean you know again i think what's a
little different at least here
the optics are better for detroit as far
as just this year's concern not in
totality not even it's not comparable to
billy o'brien i mean billy o'brien like
we talked about four to six years
afc south champ that's different but
i still think they win a game in arizona
very competitive last week against new
orleans i mean the game is there to
present itself
you know they're going to kick
themselves and and and you know in the
butt
all year long about blowing week one
because man would they feel a whole lot
different if they were going on this bye
week two and two
because and this is why you know my
thing i'll say here is
this is why i don't rush to any
decisions quite yet they got the jaguars
the falcons the colts the vikings
the football team the carolina panthers
i can sit here mike and not to say
they're going to win all of them
but i certainly can look at every game
that we just mentioned
uh you know five out of the next six
games
other than the colts i could sit there
and go detroit can beat jacksonville
detroit can beat atlanta
detroit can beat minnesota detroit can
beat the football team
detroit can beat carolina so i would
wait to kind of see how that
kind of shuffles out i think if i was
running detroit just to see where we go
there and then maybe make a decision i
don't know you agree with me
that or not i agree with you i agree
with you i i don't think you do it
during the season
i think last year they made it clear
that they were going to give it another
year and a lot can still happen over the
final 12 games but i'll tell you what
coming up fairly soon
maybe by thanksgiving it well definitely
by thanksgiving
we're going to be able to do an
apples-to-apples comparison of
matt patricia's record in jim caldwell's
record caldwell was 36 and 28
in four seasons patricia is 10 and 25.
he loses three more games
it's whatever he is far below 36
and 28 versus caldwell's 36-28 and i
think that's when it potentially reaches
critical mass
from the standpoint of the fans and and
that was one thing that
that was clear last year when martha
ford
said at the end of the year that they're
coming back it was it was
clear that that they're going to listen
to the customers
so at some point the customers are going
to get pretty loud and if they are going
to listen to the customers now
now uh martha ford has turned over the
reins to sheila fordham
who's running the team but at some point
that's part of it because ultimately
you've got to convince people
to give up their time their money and
their passion
to support your product you don't want
your fan base to become ambivalent no
it's
you know eerie here's the thing look i
know
matt patricia said when he went to
detroit he's going to do it his way he's
going to be his guy but when you're with
bill belichick for 15 years
a lot of the way belichick does things
seep into the way you do things
it just does and that patriot way
if you don't win it's not sustainable
you have to win bill belichick would
have been gone in new england
if he didn't win now everybody's got to
win right but what i'm saying is yeah i
know
it's gotta work it's gotta pop and it's
gotta happen sooner than year three
to get people to continue to buy in
because like hey we were fine with jim
caldwell
and he wasn't doing all this belichick
stuff he wasn't calling guys out and
alienating darius slay and again it's
calculated it's part of the effort
to build the team the way you want to
build it chris but if you don't win
games
you're not going to win your locker room
no you're not
you got to ha i mean especially if
you're going to really
act that bella check-in way right about
you
where it's going to be no-nonsense it's
not going to be about charisma with the
media
and yes i mean it's not a good look when
you have a few
issues with some of the star players
darius slay other things like that
certainly not it's a different day and
age and you're you know
this is a school of coaching that you
know came from bill parcells right i
mean that's kind of the thought
yeah it's it's tough it's in your face
you know my dad always says
he didn't realize his name began with a
p until after he got done playing
because he always thought it began with
f because it was always f sims f sims
whatever all those type of things
it's in your face but you're right you
want to see results and when you don't
see results it starts to wear on you
and as a player that is it's hard to
deal with but
yeah detroit's they're one of those
teams here they're teetering certainly
right now in the in the danger zone to
where if it doesn't improve if they
don't become more competitive go on some
win streak
i mean to what we talked about in
houston before it's i think it's all
over for everybody i mean patricia
bob quinn matt stafford i think it'll be
his last year
they're going to rip the band-aid off
and go to somewhere else so i i mean
we're getting to the end of the shelf
life of everything we see with the lions
here
unless they get back on track after the
bye week
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports